thank you so much for being here today
and most of all thank you so much for
giving up your spot in the Sun outside
to come back sit down and come on this
journey with us to learn about
sustainable growth I'll be joined
shortly on stage by my formidable
colleague Marie Laure Don and later by
the amazing Andy Carvel from formerly of
SoundCloud but first let's talk a little
bit about what this session is about so
what what do I mean by saying
sustainable growth solves most problems
and I'll tell you a little bit about my
goals so my first goal for today is to
introduce all of you to a very simple
yet powerful framework that you can use
to systematically accelerate the growth
trajectory of your app and the second
goal for today is to share with you some
insights of and partners or developers
that some of the mind the audience today
that are using growth tools techniques
and tactics to accelerate their app and
hopefully you'll walk away inspired and
try some of these methods yourself but
first of all let's all accept the growth
challenge so what do I mean by that I
want you to come on a journey with me to
kind of understand the importance of
having a structured approach to growth
for your app let's let's have a show of
hands here who in the audience here
considers her or himself a growth
hacking expert we should have at least
one because we have Andy in the audience
okay I see you're all shy maybe still
very full from lunch and hopefully not
half asleep yet okay so we don't have
any growth hacking experts that's
excellent you came to the right talk so
expert or not I hope that you all agree
with me when I say that
one of the important factors in why
growth or achieving sustainable growth
in the long run is so difficult is that
the individual tactics and tools and
techniques that people are using using
and not only complex in themselves but
importantly they're also very
interconnected and so it's tempting to
obsess about one or two or three
individual tactics and master them but
kind of you know lose sight over the big
picture and so for example let's look at
performance marketing so there's a
recent study that showed that marketers
are using dozens of channels and ad
formats to reach their users so this is
just looking at paid marketing and for
me that already looks like a very very
complicated subject to master so just
performance marketing but of course we
haven't even thought about or haven't
even looked at all of the organic ways
of driving users to your app and the
interdependencies between those also for
acidly so when I think about growth
growth involves much much more than user
acquisition so in fact I'm certain that
almost all of you here in the audience
today are working on strategies to
better engage and retain users in fact
at a recent Play event earlier in the
year we did roundtable discussions and
there developed almost every single
person I talked to told me that they
obsess about the onboarding experience
in their app to make sure that people or
that new users sign up or activate push
notifications to then later be able to
target them better with lifecycle
marketing campaigns now those are just
two things so onboarding experienced a
first time user experience and life
cycle marketing but there a lot of other
things that people are doing to drive
growth in engagement and retention
ultimately usage of their app and of
course eventually all of us will care
about revenue and our growing revenue
but of course how much you focus on
revenue depends on sort of the life
cycle stage of the venture that you're
working on and/or the maturity of your
product so one way that people are
optimizing or growing their revenue is
by optimizing their pricing strategy but
it's much more than just deciding on a
price so developers like top developers
like Netflix they're using a lot of very
subtle strategies and they're
experimenting with things like a price
tearing and price anchoring to influence
purchase decisions and a lot of you are
doing that as well so pricing is only
one of the many things that people are
thinking about when they're thinking
about growing revenue you know you have
to think about how do you capture value
in the first place from partners how do
you have your offer strategy what how do
you process payments so I work with a
lot of you and a lot of top partners
personally on a lot of these topics and
issues and I think it gets fairly
complex fairly quickly and luckily well
luckily there are a lot of people in the
growth hacking community growth
professionals that are looking for ways
to put some sort of structure on growth
on this wild and wild field on this
complex topics topic and trying to
understand all the interdependencies and
enable them to prioritize better and to
ultimately accelerate their growth
strategy so one of these people will be
on stage later Andy and a couple of
people around him in the growth hacking
community have been thinking a lot about
one of these tools to structure growth
and I want to give you a very brief
introduction to a growth hacking
framework so the first thing that you
should do is actually to stake to take a
step back and so just
before looking at any of the tools
tactics and techniques think about your
high-level business objectives whatever
they are so if you're early in your in
your venture maybe you're just trying to
validate a minimum and viable product or
you're trying to double sales on mobile
or you're you know maybe looking for
investment and you want to raise a round
of investment now think about how those
high-level business objectives what do
they mean for your growth strategy for
how you define growth for yourself and
you will start to notice that you're
probably without looking at anything
individual you probably be interested to
focus more strongly on one of these
three things
maybe you'll focus on all but it will
sort of give you an initial idea on
where you might want to where you might
want to focus also of course important
not just your business objectives but
also your resources and your gun strains
and I'll think about that a little bit
I'll talk about that a little bit later
on so let's talk about how to apply that
so tactics all the things I mentioned
earlier are you kind of tools tactics
strategies that are available for you
that to you so when you and these this
by the way is not an exhaustive list
there many many other things that people
are doing but when you're evaluating an
activity think about how does this
particular activity fit into my overall
strategy so you can do that for the
activities that foster user acquisition
or accelerate user acquisition you can
do that for activities that increase
engagement and retention and you can do
that for growing revenue and I'm not
saying you should be doing all of these
things you should be looking at every
single tactic in light of your overall
objectives your resources and maybe your
constraints but then once you have sort
of assembled your toolset for growth
there's another
thing that you need to do and that is
build the right business intelligence
tools and infrastructure to be able to
track your progress and I can't
emphasize how important this is because
when you invest in these areas you're
using resources that you might use for
other things instead so you need to be
able to track the impact that you're
having that your teams are having on
these individual areas so you might want
to assign one or two actionable and
measurable KPIs to each of those
investment so maybe when you're thinking
about optimizing your play listing think
about the visit to install conversion
rate and how all the things that you're
doing is impacting that in the long run
or when you're thinking of your
onboarding flow define a metric that
captures your activation rate how good
you are at activating users when they
and how good you are introducing the
product to your users when they install
the app or when you're thinking about
growing revenue you might think okay
here's my payment here my payment
processors what's the percentage of
failed payments and how can I increase
the coverage when I enter new markets so
that's very important the KPIs and
having the measure and being able to
measure them now let's think of one or
actually explain a very simple
application of this framework it's not
you know an exercise in pretty drawings
but think of the concept of a growth
card right so you have your you've
selected the activities you want to do
you've got your own KPIs and you can
measure them now try to benchmark
against either internal goals or
industry averages so you might actually
find let's go back to the Play Store
optimization example you might actually
find that your conversion rate is
actually very good compared to you know
country benchmarks or industry
benchmarks you might find that maybe
your activation rate is okay it's not
super great but compared to you know the
girls you set for yourself it's quite
good but then you might find that
payments is really an issue and I'm just
you know using these as examples
this is how having a scorecard to guide
your growth strategy can be very very
very useful and helpful so that's enough
theory fo for one afternoon after lunch
now I would like to talk a little bit
about what our top Android developers
doing with some of these techniques and
to drive growth now I'll be focusing
mostly on the organic techniques that's
what I do in my in my day job and then
Murray will come up and talk a little
bit about paid techniques
so first up like to talk a little bit
about clue so this is a period tracking
and female health app and they're
they're based here in Berlin so late
last year we actually went through an X
or they went through an exercise and
quite similar to to the growth framework
that that I introduced just before so we
were trying to figure out where or where
the bottlenecks or which areas needed
more investment to accelerate the growth
curve on Android and one of the things
that we identified was that the in-store
conversion rate was quite lower was was
lower than it needed to be so the folks
that clue really came up with a with a
long term strategy of running lots of
little play listing experiments to
increase the conversion rate and over
the course of about six months they
increased the conversion rate by 24% and
that's huge so that means that 24% more
users install the app without spending
anything more on on advertising or doing
any PR work or anything so that's just
with the users that are already arriving
on the Play listing so just to give you
one quick one quick test so and which of
the two images do you think had a higher
conversion rate as a visit to download
conversion rate the left one or the
right one so have a show of hands for
the left one on your left okay so that's
the black one okay and the others
okay yeah so the white one there's
actually two factors there that got
tested individually and the white phone
was much more and drove drove a higher
conversion rate and the larger image so
that's a really really cool and cool
inside here the next thing I want to
talk about in terms of the tool sets
that you have available is an example
from a non-profit which is share the
meal also based here in Berlin and these
guys I'm sure also did a very
sophisticated growth analysis but one of
the restrictions that they have is that
there are nonprofit so they can't
actually spend any money on advertising
so they sort of evaluated their
constraints and then third well one of
the things we can do and we can do very
well as public relations and I think
it's a tool that's often overlooked
because it's hard to do well but when
you do it well it can be very very
powerful so they it's also hard to track
but they they have to track the impact
so they estimate about 50% of all so
total installs and we're driven by
public relations and a couple of the the
insights there is you need to really
focus on excellent messaging and having
the right hooks and also to combine
public relations with other initiatives
such as partnerships work or maybe fresh
press work partnerships and maybe viral
hooks something like that I also want to
talk a little bit about a virality so um
I'm sure you guys all know dubsmash I
don't know if anyone from dubsmash is
here today I think so no and maybe you
don't want to you don't want to say and
so dubsmash is a social video messaging
platform and basically what it does it
it allows you to create videos of
yourself that are dubbed and you can
lip-sync two songs and this is really
really fun and in a waver ality is built
into the product right it's it's not
very fun looking at your own at yourself
singing along to songs so you kind of
you know
sharing and reaching other users is
built-in and it has been hugely
successful and growth has been
phenomenal but the point I want to make
is that even if virality isn't built
into your product so if your product
isn't the perfect fit for viral
mechanics and there is a couple of
things that you can look out for to make
sure that and you make sharing as easy
as possible so there are really two
factors one is called it has a very fun
name it's called the K factor and it
basically means it describes how many
new users does one user bring into the
app so that's something that you might
want to that you might want to work on
improving by making it easier to share
and with other users so that can have a
really nice impact on your sort of
organic growth another factor that you
might want to look at is the cycle time
and that just means how short or how
long is the interval between me sharing
with friends and those friends coming
back to the app or installing the app
for the first time and then sharing
again so shortening that time can also
be a very very very powerful factor of
increasing the viral growth of your app
so think about making sharing easy
accessible and encouraging and
centralizing sharing one thing one final
thing I want to talk about in this in
this quick session is cross promotion so
cross promotion if you already have a
popular app can be very very powerful
tools so freeletics and did this very
well so for me cross promotion isn't
just you know injecting a an
interstitial and showing it to all your
existing users to promote a new product
but doing it in a clever way works very
well so for example freeletics injected
nutrition information - and the Activity
Stream for all their bodyweight users
and so that got people who are just
interested in Fitness interested in
nutrition as well and some of them
clicked through - to the app and their
various other subtle way
of using cross-promotion to promote a
new product and this was very very very
successful for freeletics so when they
launched the nutrition app and almost
all of the sales were made to existing
users of existing apps so that's my part
talking about organic tactics and I'd
now like to ask Marie on stage talk a
little bit about performance marketing
hi everyone at Google i/o we announced
our mobile app install ads had driven
over two billion installs this number is
now travillian this is truly growth
hacking how did we achieve that at
Google we take up promotion very
seriously and have been heavily
investing in building us the tools that
will help you drive installs and also
make sure that your users stay active
within the app if you've heard earlier
in the opening that we had launched
universal app campaigns last year as a
very simple way to actually show your
ads on the full set of our inventory
which include Google search the Google
Play Store our Google Display Network
and YouTube what you need to run
Universal ad campaigns is only full line
of text then we do the rest for you we
generate creatives using your Play Store
assets and we use for example your app
icon then we run the apps the ads and
optimize them for you
automatically through our machine
learning solution or conversion
optimizer so this has been extremely
successful and helped a lot of
advertisers to drive installs with
success
now I like to do a show of hands but
because I feel the energy is a bit down
after lunch I'd like you to stand up if
you if you already use paid marketing
before can you please stand up if you
use performance marketing so let's say
about half the room all right now you
everybody sit down okay
so hopefully you moved and now you're
energized again right and so obviously
if you stood up or if you didn't
universal app campaigns is truly
something I encourage you to to look at
we have very sophisticated players using
it in the industry and also our smaller
players so this is really something I'd
like I'd like you to take away today now
we're going to explore a couple of
different campaign types that can be
used and help you drive installs and app
engagement so the first one I'm going to
talk about is video so video campaigns
are really good if you want especially
to build a brand awareness right and
also drive installs for the most
successful advertisers out there we've
noticed that usually videos would
trigger users with higher lifetime value
here we have the example of musician so
if you want to become Jimi Hendrix
tomorrow use musician you'll learn how
to play guitar what they did if they use
videos in their ad campaigns and they
managed to increase their installs over
a hundred and thirty six percent other
results they launched the campaigns in
over 50 different countries a couple of
tips to make sure that your videos can
be very successful
for a promotion you need very short
videos so that's the first point
we recommend less than 20 seconds second
tip make sure that you're showing the
brand in the first second of the video
third tip you make sure that you also
show the users how to use the app so use
a demo very easily use screenshots from
your app so that the user can understand
actually what your app is about finally
and last tip for successful videos make
sure you have a clear call-to-action at
the end the users needs to click at the
end of the video to be redirected to the
store and then install your app is done
I'm going to move forward to the sank
second campaign type I'm going to talk
about which is search so search is
enabling you to drive installs at scale
and will allow you to reach users that
are going to look for apps similar to
use so here you can see get get is the
taxis service application they run
search campaign both on the Google
search Network and the Google Play Store
and they saw an increase up to 60% I
think in red in Russia they saw lower
CPI of 60% so this was very successful
for them and at the same time they
managed to exceed their return on
investment by 150 percent the next
campaign type I like to talk about is
once you've decided to go beyond
installs so we all know that user
engagement and making sure that users
stay active within the app is extremely
important so here the idea is really to
shift from the installs to actually
start monitoring and optimizing
for in-app events or in-app activities
this example is the one of happen as
anyone knows happen here it's a dating
app so alright so what they did is they
actually decided to do that they wanted
to keep monitoring installs but move a
bit of way further than the funnel and
start optimizing for registrations so
they started building up display
campaign to optimize for registration
and they managed to decrease by 68% the
cost per registration in one of their
most expensive segments which was women
over 25 so this really worked well for
them if I take other example and I'm
thinking about education apps today then
optimizing for registration might be
important all the things that you might
want to optimize for is a tutorial
completion for example or is also
optimized for users who have who are
reaching a certain number of classing
within within your app all purchases at
ultimately retailers so the same they
will try to track different things and
optimize for different things for
example a product view and they might
also want to optimize for a search
perform within the app they might want
to optimize for an item added two
baskets and ultimately even go to the
end of the funnel and optimize for
purchase finally the last piece I like
to talk about is engagement and how to
drive successful engagement campaigns so
for engagement you need to be very clear
with regards to the strategy you want to
adopt so there could be several
strategies if you're a gaming
application you might want to go after
the users that have achieved level 5
within your game
or above because you know those users
are going to be the most profitable for
you the ones driving the most lifetime
value you could also very simply decide
to reengage all the users who have
already installed the app in the case of
foodpanda which is one of our
berlin-based partner i decided what they
decided to do through their engagement
display campaigns is to optimize and go
after the users who had installed the
app or who had already made a purchase
and this was extremely successful 71%
decrease in cost per install and 37%
more sales when they were comparing the
results of their ad campaigns to their
previously run desktop campaigns so it
was very very successful and paid off a
lot for them so with that other recap a
couple of ways to run paid acquisitions
today and we engage your users through
universal app campaigns video campaigns
search optimising beyond the install for
in-app events and finally run
reengagement campaign thank you and with
that I'm handing over to max thank you
Thank You Marie
so I hope that there was something
interesting there for everyone some
inspiration some ideas or something that
partners or developers here in the
audience are doing so I want to remind
you we're all here today so let's chat
so if you found anything or heard
anything that was interesting I'm sure
that Sebastian is very interested in
chatting to you and listen to listen to
his and or if you're interested in PR
he's an expert in it so and think about
what what was useful there and think of
how you can apply it to your to your
project to your app now I want to
recognize the fact that growth strategy
doesn't happen in a vacuum
so it's very very very
important to have a great team in the
culture to support that so we were
talking to some of what we thought were
very successful developers and experts
in the area so think of that of the 76
million total installs and that ran
tastic has generated on play 95 percent
were generated organically I think that
is a phenomenal number and the head of
growth at a Tran tastic Mario he's very
very proud of that KPI because it's in
its a very good indicator that they're
doing something right in there you know
with their growth team and with their
growth strategy so the first lesson when
I talked to him the first lesson that he
had to me I had for me was if you want
to do growth right it can't be a
strategy so much it has to be at the
core of the culture and it has to inform
everything you do so what does he mean
by that well it means that their growth
culture is codified in a set of
principles at runtastic so one of the
principles for examples is growth is
never done or another principle is maths
and metrics don't lie but they don't
tell everything so growth culture is
encapsulated in these principles and
these principles then inform all the
processes that rent or that people that
rent or how people that ran tastic works
it informs how the teams are staffed and
what tactics those teams employ so he
shared with me this very high-level view
of how their product managers designers
and engineers work together to create
their app so and I think it and it
encapsulates well the principles at work
so it applies data but it doesn't rely
on data and entirely the feedback is
also qualitative and it also means that
growth has never done so you have these
continuous feedback loops of how they do
development
another key thing I think that that you
need to remind yourself is is that
growth strategy is very cross-functional
it's a cross-functional endeavor and so
the quality of your execution will
depend on assembling the right skill set
and the right people in your team to
actually execute well so I hope that
yeah as I said before you chat to
through other developers here and really
try to get to the bottom of how and how
other people in the in the industry are
set up to drive growth one last thing I
want to emphasize is the importance of
continuously tracking your progress
whether you use a growth scorecard or
some other device it's important with
successful growth growth strategy to
flag problems early on so that you know
whether you're the investments you're
making and bringing you closer to the
goals you've stated for your KPIs and to
also reevaluate your growth strategy
continuously as internal and external
factors change so that was the first
part of this presentation before I call
on and II just want to give you a very
quick summary so first we looked at how
complex the whole topic of growth is but
then we likely introduced a very simple
tool the growth framework to deal with
this and the first step is to look at
your high-level business objectives to
define what growth means to you for you
and for your business and then to really
focus only on the techniques that make
sense for you the tactics and the tools
that make sense for you and importantly
be able to track the impact that you're
having also define really good KPIs for
you that are measurable and actionable
and and have some sort of way of making
sure you visualize whether you're on
track and then to continuously look at
the data as it comes in and track your
progress
to make sure you're on track and to make
changes as necessary now Maria and I we
covered the framework we gave you some
examples I'm thrilled to handle
to Andi who until recently was a product
manager at SoundCloud and he is
currently a growth hacker please
I hope he'll them he'll he'll share you
some he'll share with you some
interesting insights of how SoundCloud
lives in brief growth so thank you very
much thanks it's a pleasure to be here
so a beautiful day so thanks for being
in here and not outside in there in the
sunshine yeah so as Mac said I actually
just finished at SoundCloud literally on
the first except since 1st of September
I'm now working with another X
SoundCloud er we set up a mobile growth
consultancy so we're helping companies
with exactly this kind of stuff like
applying the mobile growth stack
framework and also writing about a
growth top except mobile growth stack
calm but spent the last four and a half
years at SoundCloud working on mobile
growth and the last year and a half of
that was leading a cross-functional team
focused on user retention which I'm
going to talk about a little bit today
and tell you why I think it's the the
most important growth metric and just
give you a little bit of insight into
like some of the things that we we did
at SoundCloud to to increase retention
so retention it's really scary when you
look at this graph on the right this is
the graph that I often refer to it was
published by Andrew Chen in one of his
his blog posts and it shows the the
average retention of Android apps in the
Play Store and it shows that the blue
line there at the top is that the top 10
like apps in the top 10 and what you see
on this curve is that even a top 10 app
loses 50% of its users in the first 90
days and if the app is not in the top
ten it's it's likely to be retaining
users significantly poorer than that
it's it's a really tough game to retain
users because the switching cost of like
you know for a user to to switch to
another app or just to you know discard
your app is basically zero
it's a constant challenge to keep your
users engaged and retained and of course
if you're spending money on marketing
it's it's really scary to think that
actually you're paying to acquire users
who are probably not going to stick
around so anything you can do to improve
retention gives you compound growth over
the long term and yeah it's going to
also be a multiplier on your acquisition
efforts so at Sound Cloud the way that
we looked at retention was I mean you
can think about retention in terms of
like when you when you look at your
users in any given period so for example
here is a example from the the may users
at SoundCloud they broke into these
these three different buckets so you can
think about you always have some new
users who've just arrived and then at
some time we talked about repeat and
returning users so I'm going to just
take a moment to explain the difference
between those two buckets so a repeat
user is someone who was here in the last
period and he's here again this period
or she is here again this period so this
is a oil user who is currently engaged
and is using your app regularly what you
often find is that there's also a large
bucket of what what we referred to as
returning users so these are users who
were not seen in the last period so the
period that said they were not seen last
month but they're here this month but
they signed up more than one month ago
and this bucket actually is usually
pretty large particularly few apps been
around for a while and these users
haven't necessarily turned in the case
in the sense of like that they've really
abandoned your app they might just be
very casual users who you know maybe
they use use your app you know once or
twice a month or you know a few times a
year and depending on your app and the
particular kind of use case that you're
solving maybe that's that's okay but
probably most apps you really want users
coming back every week or even every day
or even multiple times per day so really
the way that we approached it at
SoundCloud was that we wanted people
listening to music on SoundCloud every
day preferably for many hours and so
really it was all about growing that
repeat user bucket turning new users
into repeat users and then keeping
there and then yeah reactivating users
who who had lapsed but reactivation is
really tough and I'll talk a bit more
about that later so how do we like
approach this idea of like keeping users
engaged keeping keeping users from
dropping out of this loop and it's like
the way that the way that I sort of
conceptualize it is that you're building
growth machines you want to build
repeatable loops processes which through
testing you've proven to like have a
strong impact or a positive impact at
least on on your your retention numbers
so this could be I'll talk about
activity notifications as a prime
example of this in a minute but there
are other things you can do
could be a loyalty scheme that sort of
fear with point or gamification
something like this anything you can do
that basically you can put it on sort of
autopilot once if you test it and
optimize it and iterate it on it to a
certain level that it just keeps going
and it keeps like pushing some users
into a higher engaged State and
basically interacting with users ideally
before they churn and so I'll talk a
little bit about activity notifications
which was actually one of the projects
that I spent most of the last year
really building up at SoundCloud was to
build out a new activity notification
infrastructure for the company so what
our activity notifications they're sort
of real-time notifications could be push
which was actually the first channel
that we deployed them to but can also be
over email could be SMS the channel is
less important I guess than the than the
concept which is that you're you're
getting in touch with the user to tell
them something hopefully interesting and
relevant to them in a timely fashion
about something that's happened when
they're they're not in the app now it's
not always applicable to every app
scenario but at Sound Cloud for example
there are plenty of things that happen
when you're not in the app that you
might be interested in it could be that
artist that you're following have
released new tracks and you might want
to be told about them because you might
want to come and listen to them
it could be that I've created a playlist
and somebody has interacted with it
somebody
liked it or reposted it somewhere and so
these kind of like social interaction
social signals or just new content new
content is a great one and it's
definitely was the highest performer for
for SoundCloud in terms of being able to
tell people that there's hey there's new
music that you might want to come and
listen to was fantastic
in terms of performance so I mean just
to give you some idea with the new
notifications that we rolled out we
built out like five new notification
types and like between that combination
we were able to increase retention by
around 5% like absolute percentage
points which is which is yeah pretty
significant so like what do we actually
build it's more than just coding like
these these notifications to say okay
tell the user that something happened
like what we actually wanted to build
was a measurement and experimental
framework around that such that we're
actually able to test and iterate on
these notifications and to measure the
impact measurement is really a tough
thing with retention because everything
affects retention like you know any
product change that you make is likely
to affect your attention your
acquisition mix will also affect your
attention so it's really important when
you're you know running any initiative
that you you hope to improve retention
that you're always have some kind of
control group that is not exposed to
whatever change that you're going to
make and that that control group is
basically representing everything else
that's going on in the platform because
it's it's quite a volatile number
typically so we always had a group of
users who never received any
notifications and then we would test our
new notifications with with with test
groups an a/b test all the while with
copy with timing with yeah the different
kind of mix and combination of
notifications that we would send so this
there's a lot of experiments to run and
and just as Max was saying it's
something that's never really done it's
never really finished so yeah like
SoundCloud will continue to iterate on
these notifications to build out new
types and I think they're the next phase
now that we have
sort of a pretty pretty cool
notification system is that they'll
start to add like a layer of
intelligence on top of that so getting
smarter about optimizing for relevance
of notifications which is super
important
and yeah so sort of final points just on
like how to build good notifications
it's really all about personalization
and again this kind of comes back to the
point about iteration so we have we have
a reactivation notification that we do
we send to users when we haven't seen
them in the app for five days at Sound
Cloud because we we figured out again
through testing that five days was a
good time to interact with the user
before they really likely to churn
completely but there it's already sort
of risk of churn at that point so we'd
send them a notification and and
probably like a lot of people who who
start off with with reactivation we
started with something very basic it was
like hey come back and find more music
on soundcloud like basically just a very
generic like we miss you kind of message
and yeah perhaps unsurprisingly that the
click ride was was super poor the impact
was you know it was still worth having
but it was pretty minimal and so we
thought okay how can we iterate on that
so we what we ended up with which is
performing way better was a kind of a
three tiered approach where we look at
like okay has this user shown some kind
of engagement within the app that we can
use in you know reactivation message so
we looked at how the user liked the
track because that's a really high level
of engagement if they've actually hit
the like button and so if a user liked a
track in the past we look at that the
last track that they liked and in that
reactivation message we say hey not just
come back and find some more music on
sampler but we say hey come back and
find some more music from artist X
artist X being the creator of the track
that they liked and if they haven't
liked to track then we look at the last
track that they played and we use that
as a signal and we personalize it in the
same way so if I listen to a Britney
Spears track my last track then we'd say
hey come back and find more music from
Britney Spears and we found that these
you know by by using what you know about
the users
usage history in those messages you can
really increase the click rate
dramatically I mean I think it was
something like a 5x increase in our
click rate albeit from a very low base
yeah time of day can also be pretty
important probably a good idea not to be
sending push notifications to people in
the middle of the night of course if
it's a real-time notification if it's
important enough maybe some people want
to be woken up but yeah it's like again
it's something to test and yeah really
importantly also to give users like
granular control over notifications if
they can just opt in or out of
notifications in general that's going to
really limit your like boldness when
you're testing new things because like
you'll be worried about people opting
out of push notifications altogether
which is a valid concern if you give
users the option to opt out of every
individual class of notifications so in
other words say I want to be told about
new tracks but I don't care if people
are following me I don't want to be be
notified about that by giving people
that granular level of control you can
be like more experimental and try bigger
ideas because you can that you likely
that they'll just opt out of that
particular type of notification rather
than all of your notifications so you
can minimize and mitigate against
negative impact yep that's it that's my
short lessons learned on building an
activity notification system and yeah
thanks very much
you